[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
this is the channel where we explain it
so you don't have to do with Avengers
endgame possessing several moments that
I heavily into the law of the MCU fans
have started to go back and re-watch the
older movies in the series with fresh
eyes desperately searching for tie-ins
to the recently released movie one of
the best theories that's just dropped
comes in the form of old Steve Rogers
being a Peggy Carr as funeral in Captain
America's Civil War now from here on out
the videos full spoilers ahead in whilst
I've already given some things away the
next part will be massively diving into
the ending of Avengers endgame so if you
don't want anything ruin it then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my MCU fan theory okay so
just a quick recap of the ending of a
bench's endgame after saving the
universe from Thanos in order to stop it
from collapsing further Steve Rogers
must travel back in time to place the
Infinity stones back to their correct
positions however instead of returning
himself Steve decides to stay in the
past in order to live out the rest of
his life
with his long-lost loved Peggy Carter
whilst fans have wondered whether this
was always the case and Kevin Feige has
remained rather tight-lipped on the
subject even avoiding it in his recent
ask me anything on reddit there is a
character that carries carter's coffin
that looks a lot like old Steve from
behind the next image comes directly
from that scene and whilst we never see
the pallbearers face from behind he has
a striking resemblance to old cap in
addition to this he also stands on the
opposite side of where young Steve is
seated possibly to hide his face so that
he doesn't create another problem
called in a time line in order to be
carrying the coffin that this character
must have been pretty close to Carter
and whilst we will probably never have
complete confirmation it's still nice to
speculate that this was the case Marvel
have been known to retroactively Lee go
back and reconfirm character appearances
in early movies such as young Peter
Parker being an Iron Man 2 and this
would be amazing if one of the heads of
the studios came out and confirmed that
this was the case obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this theory and if
you'd like to read the full thread on
reddit then you can find it linked in
the description below if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my recent breakdown
of the x-men movie timeline which
finally sorts out all of the continuity
problems in the universe we've also just
launched a merchandise section on the
channel so if you'd like to support the
videos and get something back from it
then please click the links in the boxes
below it makes videos like as possible
and the team and I massively appreciate
it so thank you this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]